my contribution to dinner is a local
fish tilapia cook with ingredients I've
raided from the ladder so what do you
put in lemon a preserved lemon yeah some
Rosemary some garlic yeah just inside my
daughter she's the same age seven years
old and she already Cooks she wants see
to teacher okay so we can do this
together then we want to pour all the r
can can I talk what do you need to make
all this noise I'm chopping garlic
what's wrong with me we need to put all
the uh almonds we need put all the dry
fruits in there and then we mix it and
we make it into a uh uh sweet bread
sweet bread
right I can't hold them up I have never
done anything like this in my
[Music]
life not great so this fish it's going
to be grilled I'm just worried it's not
going to feed us all is there any
meat yeah
she has prepared
something that's the head of the sheep
wow has he got the brains in there
everything being here it makes you
realize that we have far too many things
in life can she say bra gly Bravo bra
bra people could very happily live in a
place like this in this desert where
there is nothing
if your family are together everybody's
happy egg wash see egg wash did you see
any eggs I heard a chicken do you want
some eggs now how many
just she's telling her what she hides
her eggs she revealing it she hides her
eggs that oh my goodness me you got it
yeah in the
wardrope uh messy if you glaze this it's
going to come out so beautifully I know
but the problem is the flour that they
use is it
boiled a little bit of oil on the boat
just not not to stick how do we turn the
gas
up what's that there the poo of the
goats goat we put the goat poo in
there as well and it's natural and it's
giving a good taste to the food it steam
yes oh
okay some poo the is in they what
what are you doing this is the old star
of living you know in this desert and
they're happy it's pretty remarkable we
going to eat together there around that
very fire I mean this is proper
Hospitality oh wow this looks beautiful
oh gra fantastic thank you this is a
wonderful treat back home we'll be
getting ready with turkeys and beef and
this is completely different Mr laros is
going to service now wow look at the
Children's faces if I give this to my
kids they will never talk to me again
trust me it is delicious it's important
for the guest to eat the eyeballs here
as a tradition right oh really this is
going to be like a busha
trial it's for me this one with the eye
for the
guest you have the second eye of the
Sheep No No for you listen to don't arue
see yeah what did he get the
dick it's the head oh okay you don't
have that in the head unless you're a
dick head
do we say grace we say
bis M thank you I've got a uh I've got a
cheap this Chap's head's delicious
really
good oh my God how's the
eyeball
you